on le sait on a besoin des arbres en
ville pour purifier l'air pour lutter
contre les îlots de chaleur mais on a
aussi besoin d'électricité et souvent
les branches et les fils électriques ne
font pas bon ménage Hydro-Québec mène
d'ailleurs un projet pour mieux
contrôler la croissance des arbres en
ville jusqu'à présent la solution
étudiée bien originale ne plaît pas à
tous
[Musique]
rien n'est mieux qu'une vue du haut
désert de la ville de Saint-Lambert pour
constater la place des arbres dans cette
municipalité au sud de Montréal ils
occupent 30% de la superficie
mais cette canopée comme on l'appelle
est sévèrement déformée c'est le
résultat de l'élagage préventif
d'Hydro-Québec qui cherchent à réduire
les contacts entre les branches et les
fils à l'origine des pannes de courant
[Musique]
certaines
arbres au point de coupe ils deviennent
moins résistants aux intempéries en 2019
une solution originale a été adoptée
quelques arbres comme celui-ci ont été
plantés directement en dessous des fils
électriques
[Musique]
Christian Mercier titulaire d'une chair
de recherche sur le contrôle de la
croissance des arbres sa faire sur le
terrain avec un de ses étudiants afin de
mettre en place le premier prototype
on plante les poteaux et on pose les
bras allons-y
son équipe cherche à faire croire les
abres en V autour des fils électriques
on essaie de différentes techniques pour
essayer de d'éduquer les armes à pousser
de façon transversale au lieu de pousser
en hauteur pour éviter les fils
électriques et avec des tuteurs en métal
on va forcer des branches à pousser de
façon latérale
voilà c'est bon
on va le mettre de l'autre côté
ouais
ce qu'on appelle un genre de chapeau
capuchon l'idée c'est que la lumière à
l'intérieur est beaucoup plus faible en
fait la lumière à l'intérieur est à peu
près 5 à 10 % de ce que on a en pleine
lumière ce qui est reproduit des
conditions naturelles qu'on trouve sous
la forêt
donc là on va vraiment prendre ses
branches là
c'est
là et à ce moment là on va mettre son
énergie sur les branches latérales et on
espère et c'est ça qu'on veut tester que
ça va induire un genre de de branche
latérale principal de façon naturelle
sans avoir besoin de revenir élaguer
continuellement les tiges principales
Hydro-Québec finance la recherche
il faut dire que la société d'État voit
ses coûts d'élagage augmenter
constamment avec les changements
climatiques qui mettent les arbres à rue
des preuves de 64 millions de dollars en
2016 ses coûts sont passés à 100
millions l'an dernier l'expérience en
cours pourrait aussi aider à redorer le
blason de la société d'État auprès des
citoyens
je vous cacherai pas que nos
interventions d'élagage finalement ces
interventions là sont pas toujours
acceptables parce que juger inesthétique
par plusieurs donc c'est en voulant
réduire l'intervention qu'on fait sur
les armes on pourrait peut-être en
arriver à avoir des interventions plus
esthétiques donc plus socialement que ça
tombe est-ce que c'est vraiment plus
acceptable nous avons posé la question à
des résidences de Saint-Lambert
je vais vous montrer de quoi ça a l'air
ce qu'on fait devant une autre résidence
de Saint-Lambert point de vue esthétique
comment vous trouvez ça je vais trouver
ça
moi j'aime les âmes nature
c'est quelque chose de relatif moi quand
je regarde ça je trouve ça magnifique en
terme de recherche je vois des des
traitements qui vont nous apporter des
réponses à long terme mais l'idée c'est
qu'on va faire ça seulement pour 5 à 10
ans donc évidemment pour quelqu'un 5 à
10 ans c'est quand même assez long mais
la durée de vie d'un arbre c'est 100 150
ans donc c'est vraiment je dirais un mal
nécessaire à court terme pour un
bienfait un arbre qui est plus en santé
qu'une meilleure femme un meilleur
esthétisme et qui va vraiment continuer
à fournir des bénéfices à long terme
c'est pas fou mais est-ce que c'est
prouvé que c'est une bonne solution
c'est la bonne solution l'écologie c'est
quoi
c'est des prends soin des arbres n'a pas
des fils qu'on peut enfouir sur la terre
ça ils peuvent le faire pourquoi qu'ils
le font pas question d'argent politique
je pense qu'il faut qu'on commence à
repenser à une rendu au point où on
cherche comme on va modifier la
croissance des arbres pour accommoder
nos films mais là il commence à être
temps qu'on pense comment est-ce qu'on
va les enfants
c'est quand même pas mal moins grave de
voir des branches détournées
tranquillement au fil du temps puis qui
qui englobe le fil de façon sécuritaire
qui est de voir le fil puis une radiale
complète à 3 mètres en dessous par pour
des raisons de sécurité à la ville de
Saint-Lambert on est ravis de
l'expérience d'autant plus que les
essences d'arbres plantés ont été
sélectionnés en fonction de leur
résistance au vent à la sécheresse de la
profondeur de leur enracinement et de la
qualité de l'azote dans leur feuille
on sait de toute façon que l'indice de
canapé va baisser à cause de la grume du
frêne qui est quand même très actif sur
le territoire et on veut le rattraper le
plus vite possible mais le fait de
planter le bon arbre au bon endroit avec
Hydro-Québec en faisant ce projet pilote
là fait en sorte qu'on va on va éviter
d'abattre et de replanter d'abattre et
de replanter parce qu'on fait des
mauvais choix on fait les tests pour
faire les meilleurs choix possible pour
la suite
[Musique]
mais seule une douzaine d'arbres seront
soumis à l'expérimentation à
Saint-Lambert le véritable test c'est
ici qu'il se déroulera à Saint-Bruno ou
180 arbres ont été plantés
c'est les mêmes les mêmes approches
c'est les mêmes techniques de conduite
de cette dame qui vont être appliquées
ici mais dans un laboratoire laboratoire
si elle ouvert mais dans un laboratoire
l'élément est intéressant je vous dirais
d'une plantation au milieu comme ça
c'est
d'éliminer la majorité des stress qui
peuvent être occasionnés et qui nous
amèneraient de la distorsion au niveau
de notre analyste c'est que par la suite
dans une ville comme Saint-Lambert dans
chaque condition le sol va être
différent la proximité des autres
espèces d'art va être différents la
proximité de la maison et ça c'est
toutes des variables qui vont affecter
les résultats qu'on va obtenir ce qu'on
appelle du bruit en terme statistique et
donc ça va être plus difficile d'isoler
les faits du traitement à Saint-Bruno et
là on va pouvoir vraiment isoler l'effet
de une structure en métal élagage versus
capuchon versus pas d'élagage du tout il
va avoir même un contrôle on va avoir
des espèces qu'on va on ne va pas
élaguer parce qu'on veut toujours
comparer avec ce qu'on appelle un
contrôle en niveau au niveau
scientifique donc on va pouvoir prendre
des échantillons de racines dans le sol
et voir quand on fait des traitements
comme ça qu'est-ce qui se passe au
niveau de l'arbre au niveau de sa
croissance de son éco physiologie de
façon globale
à terme 600 arbres seront plantés ici
lorsque l'expérience aura livré ses
fruits dans une quinzaine d'années de
quoi aura l'air le paysage sur ce
terrain ce qu'on aimerait voir c'est un
arbre qui a développé deux ou trois
branches latérales très tôt avoir un
arbre qui a l'air plus naturel qui est
en santé et qui demande moins d'élagage
par la suite donc des coûts pour la
société on a un nombre d'individus à un
nombre d'arbres qui est statiquement
intéressant donc moi je suis vraiment
confiant que ce projet-là va être
porteur il va être porteur de
belles solutions pour l'avenir